bonjour je m'appelle grimoire els j'ai
21 ans j'habite à la possession j'ai le
PM B je possède un véhicule j'aimerais
faire un CP pâtisserie en
apprentissage je suis actuellement 2e
année de BTS assistante de gestion de
PME PMI je n'ai pas de formation
particulière concernant la pâtisserie
mais j'ai déjà assisté mon père qui
était lui pâtissier je fais pas mal de
préparation de gâteaux chez moi comme
des tartes aux pommes aux fraises des
génoises des crèmes pâtissières aussi
cependant j'ai effectué pas mal de
stages dans des entreprises je recherche
une pâtisserie dans l'Ouest prête à
m'accueillir plus tard j'aimerais créer
une pâtisserie c'est pour cela que
j'aimerais faire ce CP
pâtisserie dans le but d'apprendre la
pratique en SA que j'ai déjà une base en
gestion cela reste un avantage pour moi
je suis très motivée vous ne serez pas
déçu par mon travail